I can't believe this I know right it's
very insir every time I hang out like I
love seeing you but I also don't like it
did you do that did you invent that
pepper yeah
[Music]
why hey what's going on everybody for
first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and it's a
special day we have a murderous row of
spicy food Legends and we're here to
explore the sick twisted and wonderful
world of pepper X now officially the
hottest pepper in the entire world and
I'm joined by a few guys who need no
introduction to OG hot ones fans we have
the founder of heatness Noah chamber in
the building and smok and Ed Curry the
sick twisted mind behind peppera and of
course the owner of puckerbutt pepper
company Noah Ed welcome back to set
thank you for having us so Ed I want to
start with you hot ons fans they've seen
me on the show regaling guests with
stories about your War chest you know
the seeds that you have locked away the
peppers that you have locked away for a
rainy day whenever someone decides to
challenge your pepper Supremacy was
pepper x one of those peppers like is it
something that's been in the war chest
for a decade plus well you know we've
stabilized it a while ago and it's been
in the war chest for about a decade now
and we've just been waiting to take it
out but no one's been able to take us
out so I decided to bring it out to the
world can you take me through the
science of peppera like when you create
something like this what's the culinary
experience that you're trying to create
when I'm trying to create a new pepper
uh I start with the capsinoids that are
in there Peppers everybody knows the
three major ones but the minor ones are
the ones that really bring it up so
first thing I look for is Peppers that
have those miners you can make something
really really hot but if it tastes like
crap you can't do anything with it so
the second thing is looking for flavor
uh so when we bred this pepper out first
thing we look for is something to raise
that heat level to what we thought was
going to be the maximum and the second
thing was the flavor Noah I don't know
if you've seen a couple episodes so far
into Season 22 trying this experience
sauce on Wing 10 it really is a lot
headier you know I can get that kind of
head high when something's hot enough
why do you think the sauce is the
perfect vehicle for the pepper so you
see on the front of the label on every
bottle it says over 91% pepper X is
because it's just pepper X in three
forms the pure pepper the dried pepper
and the distillate of the pepper along
with some vinegar really with that we
didn't want to mask anything we wanted
the pepper to come through full steam
ahead and it just travels up the back of
your brain It's All Coming Back to Me A
lot of people have compared it to a come
up it's like it is yeah yeah it's a
different experience than just eating
something really hot it's much more
cerebral add true to form today you're
flanked by lawyers I saw someone with a
suitcase handcuff to their wrist they've
got peppera inside of the suitcase why
is growing super hot peppers why is it
so high stakes we literally people have
been trying to steal it for the last 10
years uh there's also some you know some
high corporations who want to take
what's not theirs and they're willing to
pay other people to do it so you know we
have to protect ourselves cuz this is
our pepper and we are going to just take
the world out with it I'm ready to have
so much fun with this thing I'm a little
excited
man all right this is a question for
both of you how do you unpack the
difference between you know Apollo
Carolina Reaper pepper x what sort of
culinary purpose does it serve you think
the Apollo Pepper for me I don't know
how you guys react to the Apollo sauce
well I see how you react but uh uh you
get that burn in the front and then you
get that delayed reaction of oh no
what's going on here you know what's it
and it kind of pours people towards the
flight response instead of the fight
response uh and then they get really
scared and I like the way that people
look when they they get really scared
from eating my hot sauce you know it's
just a lot of fun for me it's about the
way that we experience them right it's
the taste so with Carolina Reaper being
super floral it lends itself a lot more
to fruity flavors versus pepper X which
is a lot earthier and duskier almost and
then the other thing that I love is how
dramatic the names are pepper X Apollo
the Carolina Reaper can you talk me
through what goes into naming a pepper
when we do it at home we just get
highest kiding peppers and start
throwing out names I mean that's that's
the God's honest truth we sit around a
table I get the whole team together I
feed them stuff I said Ed what's the
pepper call we're going to make the
label and Ed said the lawyers aren't
done with the trademarks and everything
yet I said okay we're just going to
write down pepper X is a placeholder for
now and in the end the lawyers didn't
get their job done in time so we went to
print with it saying pepper X and we and
we had to change all the registration
for it and it cost me more money cuz
lawyers cost a lot of
money from time to time in the show I've
tried my best to explain the Scoville
scale and I'm not so sure that I do it
justice now that I have the experts in
front of me can you talk me through what
goes into making a Pepper or hot sauce
where it falls in terms of heat on the
Scoville scale and then what goes into
defining record-breaking heat when they
made the Scoville scale it's essentially
how much water you
dilute uh to not taste any pepper and it
used to be subjective each one of us is
going to be different if we put a
jalapeno on here how much water we have
to dilute it in now it's done with
chemistry we use an hlc okay when you
get into the millions you're talking
roller skate to space shuttle you know
they're two totally different animals
when you're trying to get that into a
sauce it's more about the flavor and the
experience not the Scoville because
there's a dilution factor that happens
when you use anything else besides the
pepper and it's other people they are
like oh I ate three Carolina Reapers I
ate 5 million Scoville no you ate 1.6
million Scoville if you have an average
size Reaper it's the Scoville does not
compound well Ed that's actually a
rather poetic segue because I have a
surprise for you today we have a
representative from Guinness World
Records here today to present you with
the plaque for creating the world's
spiciest pepper please welcome to set a
esteemed Guinness World Records
adjudicator Andy glass hey Andy Ed we
have independently verified the Scoville
heat units of pepper X and I'm pleased
to report that we've confirmed an
average rate of
2,693 th000 Scoville heat units it's a
new Guinness World Records title for the
hottest pepper thank you Andy
congratulations you're officially
amazing let's make
some look at this I can see you got
goosebumps on your arm uh this feels
like such a a moment to share with you
Ed what does it mean to add another uh
Banner to the
rafters you know it took it took a team
to get
all this is a culmination of a lot of
work by a lot of people people said it
couldn't be done they called us liars
and we Pro to him uh that pepper X is
actually the hottest pepper in the world
officially from Guinness all the time
and effort that we put in at the farm to
make sure this got stabilized and became
the hottest pepper in the world is now
validated all the risks that you guys
took in putting out the last dab and
continuing to put out dabs is now
validated and uh I just I can't tell you
how excited I am right now I really just
want to run laps around the building
well before you do that we're all happy
for you we're all very proud of you Andy
thank you so much the world obviously
and all of us here and thank you
Guinness World
[Music]
Records we've taken the peppera Deep
dive today but now it's time to do two
things number one we got to give the
people what they want somebody has got
to eat this thing and number two it
ain't going to be me but we have flown
in one of my favorite people in the
entire world my spice brother in arms
one of my favorite people whenever I see
him I just melt on the inside he brings
such happiness to my heart and I know
for OG hot ones fans he does to you as
well please welcome to set my Danish
brother Chile CLA
yeah good to see you too good to see you
too how are you doing man that's it
thank you hey brother a great honor for
me to be here H celebrating uh the new
world's hottest pepper measuring
million clouse we've eaten Reapers
together on a few occasions very
memorable experiences what's going
through your head as you prepare to take
on pepper X are you nervous right now of
course I'm
nervous the reaper officially was Meed
to 1. 642 million so this is a million
more than but that scale's logarithmic
so it's it's more like three times
hotter than a re all right well maybe in
situations like this the less that we
know the better
Victoria can we bring on the
peppers here they
come we got two here I couldn't totally
leave you hanging I had them make me a
sliver this is the first time i' I've SE
the peer eggs I just smelled it it
almost smells kind of fresh yeah you
know and that's kind you know it has a a
freshness to it it smells like um like
the skin of a a tangerine or something
yeah exactly mhm it's got a real Citrus
tone to it when you eat it this is how
we use them in the mesh okay so it's not
quite matured I'm not going to hurt you
Claus I love you it say all right
Cheers Cheers Cheers
Cheers this is Claus you're the first
person in the whole wide world to eat a
whole peppera besides me yeah yeah yeah
yeah you ready yeah I'm ready Cheers
Cheers
Cheers all right right away the
um freshness of that goes away almost
immediately Noah and then
um just that violent and ever growing um
thing that is somehow making my face
tighter like the skin of my face feels
tighter to my hat yeah you look like you
just came from the
spa my chest is the tight
part Ed oh my God I am flashing back now
yeah yeah yeah I'm every time I hang out
with you it's this you
know every time I hang out like I love
seeing you but I also don't like it
yeah it's very spicy
is it's very spicy what do you think the
flavor claw I love the flavor I think
there's some Oak in
it and pencil yeah
pencil holy even though I don't look it
I'm feeling just like Claus is feeling
oh these guys are right now feeling
there's an intense burn that happens
immediately uh and then your head kind
of feels like oh no what's going
on and then your body just starts
reacting you get it in your arms you get
it in your chest it has no real throat
burn like the reaper but that comes on
later when you're in pain I'm getting
throat burn actually I'm in I had a
little bit of a tear in my eye I'm in he
heaven I'm in
heat oh no claz is
breeding and heat and heat what I'm on
the edge of my seat I'm on the edge of
my seat CH oh I'm I'm done oh thank you
very much yeah yeah
yeah well you know what after watching
this if you would still like to test
yourself against pepper X I got good
news for you the last da experience is
available at heatness.com that's
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the world Guinness World
Record holding pepper X used in the last
dab experience be careful around your
eyes chilly let's snap it into the
credits baby oh read my arms see
you
it continues yes a
dove about two hours that's a good
tagline but what you are saying look at
his eyes he looks like he's tripping
balls I love you it I love you too CL I
love you did you do that did you invent
that pepper yeah
why I'd like to thank the
academy do I look just like Taylor Swift
yeah a young Taylor Swift yeah shake
shake it
off I'm in
heat